hey guys I was going happy Superbowl
Sunday we are on our way that were
called a mission back when Matt had as I
ate a couple days ago yeah I thought
it'd be really funny to get the dog Matt
a little powerful like what would happen
is I was on to address this website I
ordered it and then I accidentally hit
refreshment not to hit refresh and guess
what we ended up with two of them let's
see do I trust it do I trust it there we
go good one turn you took real sharp eye
Oh head so now the mat-su a control
equals joke isn't funny anymore so we're
going to go Toys R Us return them in
Matt's to buy you and hopefully they
have the g-wagen Power Wheels it's going
to be the most incredible photo every
craft to get daddy a Red Bull hat I will
ask Thoreau let suppose R Us and then
we're going to get the pizza come on he
needs a PITA yeah I love you so sorry so
watch jump so pumped dude this is insane
I made a mat guys don't worry well you
just started here
oh my camera for me to Steve
an idiot shaking my head SNA so I know
that store credit Toys R Us because they
said that PayPal doesn't let you return
things back to what I'm like but it's
still technically like a credit card so
you should be you find it yeah it's a
nice classic Hana really strike it out
here
no g-wagen no minifigures but we have
monopoly with electronic banking so
everything's great
we use on a person need to ask if they
have these because they might have him
about the r85 cares you want to get that
oh my god no I feel very defeated they
didn't have they had series 15 but they
had an empty box that was in the trash
although online it says that they do
have them at the store but they wouldn't
check for me we was trending on Twitter
today that everyone was out to his
arrest looking for many things really
yeah
cuz I would believe it no I'm sorry
alright let's give a CF card reader my
vine pj found their to roof it will do
all the things that we need to do right
here yeah that's not Ralph that look
like Ralph got what I needed flipper
flipper flipper cleaning cleaning
supplies
my arse yes these are heavy there's so
many options
I don't know what I have so Matt dropped
us off so we could get coffee and he's
going through the drive-thru at
McDonald's so I think we probably just
have to jump in through the
drive-through
okay thank you very much
you got your oatmeal yes I got my all me
on Steve you gonna mind hello under
sitting very tight
I dropped my oatmeal mine
I dropped my old meows I'm an idiot
Thanks or no pizza Mattie stay here with
Matt we're gonna miss the commercials
man you're here maybe you can do that
with your G wag all right
shoes all right do you see this
we'll see it but this one is okay yes
okay yeah show the garlic I'm so pom
oh holy moly
that's not that's to be illegal what no
you're not like will poops that should
be illegal because it looks so delicious
I cannot make a sauce in the parking
woman oh you did now he's looking at now
well okay let's see pizza and watch this
game it's opening its opening pull face
come on who you see the coca-cola
commercial guys open we try a problem
gave the warranty so since you were gone
Maddie a tam SD card Matthew
you can't leave SD cards around it was a
micro SD card and it was on this table
like well those people and then Tommy
esta cuestión post-rock comes at this
now on the raft
he throws away from home not it down
back in the 19 good boy yes good boy
well I'm not even sure what happened in
this video try even keep blogging
anymore I don't even know ya but I gotta
do laundry wasn't fun look at Matt's hat
oh those are cheap from the dog
oh I love him he's great I love Coldplay
what do you guys think of this intervals
over oh how about halftime tell me tell
me now oh yeah it just started
Cole a dozen bring it any monkeys I'm
gonna be very upset
come on is begging a DAB this sounds
exactly like that other one like the
other one of them like the other one
guys this amiibo looks like Edie except
it doesn't have a beard so I'm gonna
draw one on here's before beard okay
there's that you just think it looks
like it is it is ed I gotta say my
pictures needed put it on mm-hmm
guys I just saw the Amazon echo ad and
IRA provide that I bought one a long
time ago so we're gonna unbox it right
now man you hungry
Alexa is nature dating jenna is Eric I
don't have the answer to that I wondered
any pain it same day Matty Oh God
don't want them Maggie's
Camas episode okay come on focus up
focus up we got that we got the Amazon
echo who got the TV with a man Jenna
good let's go vamanos Alexa who is
nadeshot : took the pony what Alexa who
is nature nature in the broadest sense
is the natural physical on song world or
universe oh shoot
Alexa who's just genies Eric so seniors
Eric web designer and video editor burst
in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Alexa who is
Matthew hey sorry I didn't understand
the question I heard Alexa who is DJ
mini Matt hmm I can't find the answer to
the question I heard hey Manning owns
tons of Papa John really he's got a huge
endorsement deal a Buick I think a man
gets paid sliver in well congratulations
I'm so glad you guys won the game I
honestly did not care to one degree
absolutely no difference to me which is
really I really want to pay managed to
win I'm glad he won for you majority of
people did well sure the problem with
cam dunya is he's very cocky player yes
yes yeah I mean yeah um I don't know
it's okay - hey Alexa who won the Super
Bowl
earlier today the Broncos beat the
Panthers 24 to 10 god this is gonna be
great alright guys I'll see you whenever
hope you enjoyed the Super Bowl bye
thank you
I bet Maddie wants something to eat too
it's already done this is incredible
fast food is fast you're ready we'll
teach you a meal